[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour une nouvelle
édition de votre journal quotidien
d'information locale voici les titres de
ce à 24 octobre la plus grande part à
pharmacie de france vient d'ouvrir aux
clayes-sous-bois au coeur du centre
commercial wayne madsen 2100 mètres
carrés proposer aux clients économie
également ce soir avec un forum de
l'emploi dédié à l'apprentissage il se
déroulait hier à trappes l'apprentissage
qui depuis le début de l'année est
ouvert aux personnes jusqu'à 30 ans une
mesure du gouvernement pour lutter
contre le chômage et puis halloween ce
sera dans une semaine tout juste les
fermes de gally propose de s'y préparer
avec une série d'animations et
d'ateliers nous en parlerons en plateau
avec son responsable communication à
nous irons aussi à france miniature qui
à redécorer son parc pour l'occasion la
plus grande part et vous l'avez aperçu
cette grande parapharmacie c'est la plus
grande de france elle occupe plus de
2000 mètres carrés elle se trouve aux
clayes-sous-bois dans le centre
commercial when the sun elle a ouvert
ses portes il y a quelques jours elle
attire les clients en masse et elle
pourrait devenir la vraie locomotive de
ce centre si cela se confirme mélanie
poquet mano varaldo la plus grande part
à pharmacie de france se trouve à one
nation paris outlet aux clayes-sous-bois
soul enseigne parapharmacie lafayette
une parapharmacie standard mais qui
proposent des produits alimentaires du
made in france du bio sans lactose sans
allergènes ou encore pour les personnes
vegan je suis étonné toute chose le bio
qu'on trouve dans les magasins bio ça
c'est intéressant
l'accès aux produits alimentaires
spécifiques et de bien-être est
désormais et démocratiser une quinzaine
d'espèces leur sont consacrés dans cette
parapharmacie les français consomment de
moins en moins en prêt-à-porter plus que
3 % de leur budget alors qu'ils
consomment de plus en plus dans le monde
de la santé du bien-être avec des
dépenses qui sont multiplié par quatre
sur les 40 dernières années donc une
une forte demande des consommateurs 51
salariés dont 5 pharmaciens diplômés
sont présents dans cette parapharmacie
un investissement global de 5 millions
d'euros en partenariat avec lafayette
quarante mille produits sont présentés à
prix bas jusqu'à 30 à 40% inférieurs à
ceux couramment pratiqué c'est la
conjonction d'un réseau qui entre ces
pharmacies et parapharmacies fait 750
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
pouvoir négocier avec les laboratoires
les meilleures conditions possibles
c'est aussi un chef d'entreprise qui va
baisser ses marges
comme c'est beaucoup moins cher etc les
gens vont venir jeu en vendre plus d
étiquettes électroniques permettent aux
clients d'obtenir dans la langue
souhaitée sur leur téléphone toutes les
informations sur le produit
la fréquentation est présente dans cette
parapharmacie outlet 4000 clients en
deux jours pour leur premier week end
c'est ce qui manquait en coin ça a été
que dans les pharmacies
avec une surface de 2100 mètres carrés
la parapharmacie lafayette para one est
la plus grande part à pharmacie de
france emploie à présent et
l'apprentissage qui est désormais très
prisé pour le gouvernement il s'agit
même d'une bonne solution pour réduire
le taux de chômage au point d'avoir
repoussé en janvier dernier l'âge limite
pour pouvoir débuter
de 25 à 30 ans hier attrape un forum de
l'apprentissage était organisée à
l'initiative de la cfdt
nous sommes allés rencontrer les
recruteurs théo est étudiant en
communication il recherche une
alternance le stylo à éviter c'est bien
par écrit marne c'est bizarre aussi peut
dire que ça attirera l'attention je
trouve moi pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté il participe à un
coaching personnalisé pour perfectionner
ses candidatures c'est très intéressant
en fait d'avoir
un avis de quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît
pas et qui va pouvoir juger de
votre performance de manière
extrêmement objective en fait souvent
les personnes que je vois sont trop
modestes ils mettent pas en avant leurs
qualités c'est incroyable
c'est vraiment incroyable
on va toutes les qualités après son
coaching chaque participant peut faire
le tour de la quarantaine de stands qui
composent le forum de l'apprentissage
organisé par la cfdt
pour cette cinquième édition le syndicat
a choisi trappe
notre objectif était vraiment de mettre
en relation les jeunes ou des quartiers
alors pas forcément défavorisés mais où
il y avait une certaine discrimination
et un fort taux de chômage pour leur
ouvrir notre réseau 1
et leur faire mal
avoir un emploi un stage l'alternance
c'est pas bon pour nous avons un cv en
ligne par exemple on n'aura pas de
réponse
en fait on est devant la personne tout
de suite et appréhender notre cv donc du
coup certains si puissante année
l'événement en partenariat avec pôle
emploi convoque plusieurs acteurs de
l'emploi des entreprises qui recrutent
mais aussi des associations comme
aprodema elle propose de découvrir les
métiers de l'agroéquipement on estime
qu'ils nous manquent à peu près 6000
emplois qui restent non pourvus chaque
année et en général n'ont par exemple un
jeune qui informations dans les
formations des équipements à la fin il
entre deux et trois offres minimum
d'emploi pour cdi bien sûr lors de la
dernière édition du forum à nanterre 250
personnes avaient trouvé un emploi
sapeurs pompiers dans les yvelines
sébastien frémont est aussi l'auteur de
livres plutôt spécialiste des ouvrages
sur les états unis plus particulièrement
autour du 11 septembre nous en avons
déjà parlé plus d'une fois sur cette
antenne il s'adresse aujourd'hui aux
plus jeunes
bonsoir bonsoir ou la nef bastien
frémont vous venez avec anne-sophie
baumann de publier les dangers de la
maison je fais attention c'est un
ouvrage le voici il apparaît à l'écran
aux éditions tourbillon c'est à partir
de 3 ans tout simplement déjà pourquoi
un nouvel ouvrage sur la prévention des
risques domestiques
un nouvel ouvrage alors je partage pas
elle a passé ses propos le chiffre parle
de lui-même
vingt mille morts sur les accidents
domestiques en moyenne par an donc dont
malheureusement un nombre très important
d'enfants c'est d'ailleurs la première
cause de mortalité chez des enfants de
en très bas âge de 1 à 4 ans donc
nécessaire de les sensibiliser je pense
qu'en effet compte tenu de ces chiffres
là il est nécessaire de les sensibiliser
mais au delà de la sensibilisation s'est
même de l'éducation dont on peut parler
je pense vous êtes chef du groupement la
prévention des pompiers il ya souvent
des interventions justement auprès des
plus jeunes sur les risques domestiques
vous avez évoqué ce chiffre de 20 milles
au niveau national dont les yvelines
aussi on imagine
malheureusement oui ce sont des
interventions quotidiennes le bruit de
fond si je puis dire du nombre
d'interventions à l'échelon du
département des yvelines c'est environ
300 opérations de secours par jour donc
bien sûr parmi ces quelques centaines
d'opérations quotidiennes
on a malheureusement à déplorer des
opérations qui concernent les enfants
bien évident
là vous vous adressez aux enfants
habituellement je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure vous écrivez des ouvrages autour
des états unis du 11 septembre notamment
comment vous avez travaillé avec votre
co auteur sur cet ouvrage pour les
enfants alors une fois de plus en fait
sa part d'un ouvrage sur les états unis
puisque anne sophie baumann qui est une
spécialiste des livres pour enfants
m'avait sollicité pour la conseiller
techniquement sur un livre qu'elle
souhaitait faire sur les pompiers de new
york
donc ça tombait vraiment dans un domaine
dans lequel a priori j'ai quelques
compétences et du coup j'avais avec
grand plaisir accepté de l'aider à faire
ses ouvrages et de cette première
collaboration finalement nous est venue
l'idée de faire un livre cette fois ci
sur le dans les dangers des accidents
domestiques au sens large les incendies
mais pas seulement c'est un ouvrage qui
traite de bon nombre d'autres
malheureusement accidents potentiels
dans la maison alors s'adresse
directement aux plus jeunes c'est aux
enfants de manipuler un petit peu cet
ouvrage j'ai pas le temps de le montrer
mais les petites cases qui peuvent se
soulever c'est aux enfants de le
manipuler oui mais pas seulement et j'ai
même envie de dire surtout pas tout seul
parce qu en fait l'idée c'est de ne
surtout pas faire faire à l'enfant un
geste qui ne doit pas faire dans la
vraie vie
exemple un fer à repasser qui est encore
branché et qui est chaud il n'est pas
question que ce soit l'enfant qu'il le
débranche lui-même donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a conçu ce livre de
telle façon à ce qu'il puisse être
parcouru avec un adulte
idéalement à parents de cet enfant et
qu'ils puissent lui faire les bons
gestes qui sont dévolus à l'adulte en
présence de l'enfant qui nous l'espérons
apprendra de ces bons gestes
quels sont les risques les plus
fréquents en tout cas les accidents les
plus fréquents ces chutes étouffement
noyades intoxications
c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est à peu
près dans cet ordre là principalement
des chutes alors que ce soit dans les
escaliers
malheureusement des fois nous avons à
déplorer notre activité quotidienne fait
que nous en avons parfois à le vivre sur
certaines journées des défenestrations
d'enfants qui tombe par la fenêtre des
étages c'est important là aussi donnez
jamais laissé
un tabouret une chaise devant une
fenêtre ouverte et idéalement ne jamais
laisser de toute façon un enfant tout
seul avec une fenêtre ouverte dans une
pièce en étage
oui c'est des questions de bon sens mais
quelquefois on peut oublier pris par le
quotidien les parents sont pas toujours
vigilant sur certains petits détails
oui et puis au delà de ça la vie de tous
les jours un appel téléphonique et voilà
la vigilance est perturbé par le fait de
répondre simplement un coup de fil vous
allez aussi rencontré ce public qui vous
vous adressez lors de dédicaces par
exemple vous en avez rencontré déjà
quelques-uns il ya une autre date c'est
le 22 décembre notamment aux
clayes-sous-bois au magasin cultura il
ya déjà eu des dates c'est ça ça sera a
priori la prochaine d'accord ce qui
concerne cet ouvrage ainsi d'ailleurs
que l' ouvrage sur le livre animé des
pompiers de new york où nous en
profiterons pour le dédicacer également
effectivement au magasin cultura des
clayes-sous-bois ça vous a donné envie
de décrire d'autres ouvrages dans ce
style là justement peut-être alors on a
quelques idées qui sont pas encore
finalisés mais nous y travaillons
effectivement et encore une fois nos
filles étant d'une grande spécialiste
des ouvrages pour enfants
je lui ai soumis quelques idées qui
méritent d'être mûri et merci beaucoup
d'être passé sur ce plateau sébastien
frémont je rappelle que vous que le net
chef du groupement de prévention des
pompiers des yvelines cet ouvrage
s'appelle les dangers dans la maison je
fais attention voilà à l'antenne merci
encore à vous
[Musique]
et pour le portrait de cette semaine
direction noisy le roi dans cette
commune où réside depuis à 22 ans un
comédien professionnel son nom à bernard
pinet après avoir joué au théâtre dont
le dîner de cons et après avoir écrit
lui-même plusieurs spectacles il
continue de vivre de sa passion
à 66 ans son portrait est signée michael
et mido dans un théâtre bernard pinet
dans son élément cet habitant de noisy
le roi âgé de 66 ans a fait de la scène
sa vie tout a commencé très jeune dans
son sud natal une quarantaine d'années
avant sa venue dans les yvelines
donc j'étais premier en lecture
c'étaient les seules fois où j'étais
premier et henri citation alors il y a
une explication probablement à tout cela
je suis d'une famille du sud qui avait
une une grande bouche qui s'exprimer
haut et fort quelques années plus tard
son franc parler des rencontres le
motive à monter à paris à l'âge de 20
ans avec quelques francs en poche
aujourd'hui l'yvelinois totalise plus de
80 films à son actif traduit bien
aucun montant
tu changes de vite me prouver et je sais
bernard pinet donne également la
réplique dans trente spectacles l'un de
ses rôles phares le dîner de cons dans
la pièce le noiséens joue le rôle du
contrôleur du fisc lucien cheval c'est
un énorme succès on le joue au sens plus
de 170 fois dans les plus grands
théâtres les plus beaux théâtres de
france de suisse de belgique nous avons
joué ici au théâtre montansier et puis
c'est zénith qui était inattendu ont
passé entre johnny hallyday et starmania
après le dîner de cons bernard pinet
décide de monter des concepts de théâtre
seul en scène le comédien créé
interprète pétanque et sentiments il
pièce se joue est 300 fois et qui a
participé à quatre festival d'avignon et
à des mois molière à versailles
ben écoute tout d'abord je vais
réattaquer le sport ouais à fond les
boules je vais essayer de jouer à la
pétanque au moins une fois par semaine
c'est mon gros bébé jul vu naître du
premier mot sur le papier je les ai vus
grandir
je les ai vus se transmuter muet malgré
ses succès bernard pinet ne veut pas
entendre parler de retraite cette année
en 2019 l'artiste revient une nouvelle
fois au festival d'avignon pour défendre
son nouveau projet apocalypse
républicaine une pièce selon scène sur
l'actualité politique et sociétale
symboliquement c'est puissant c'est fort
que la première lecture mondiale ait
lieu ici dans ce festival pour moi
j'étais important vrai que le premier
drapeau soit à planter ici
ce nouveau projet écrit pendant un an
est présenté aujourd'hui en première
lecture
au fait vous connaissez la différence
entre un train et un homme politique
non le train quand il déraille
il s'arrête lui même sur la lecture je
me l'imaginé je trouve que le projet
très intéressant voilà déjà pour pour
lui pour nous et peut-être pour d'autres
ça va pas trop réagi premier niveau de
lecture non plus parce que s'il n'y a
pas matière sur une lecture à a généré
des reer ou d'aider des émotions fortes
mais
ce que j'ai entendu après me satisfait
pleinement bien sûr je crois que je vais
continuer bernard pinet espère désormais
monter son spectacle et le présenter en
2020 festival d'avignon et joué dans des
films et séries sur les prochains mois
la retraite attendra animations jeux de
piste décoration tout genre sont de
sortie à france miniature pour fêter
halloween certains monuments sont même
recouverts de toiles d'araignées une
façon pour le moins originale de
découvrir les richesses de l'hexagone un
événement qui vient clore cette saison
du parc france miniature à la fermeture
est prévue en novembre matière de 2 me
ra toile d'araignée citrouille et
corbeaux ont pris possession du parc
france miniature pendant leur tour de
france les visiteurs ont pu participer
au jeu de piste organisé spécialement
pour halloween qui faisait la fête
d'halloween en même temps c'était une
histoire de découvrir un peu la france
mais en tout petit c'était une
découverte là d'avoir halloween
ça passe a fait un petit plus au niveau
du parc lors de la balade une gargouille
un pirate une druidesse est un peintre
maudit donne des indices aux passants
pour aider la sorcière à faire sa potion
magique c'est la troupe focus qui pour
la troisième année consécutive s'occupe
des animations jeux représentent un peu
le peintre maudit en même temps de rien
degré un petit mélange donc j'ai
l'immortalité mais j'ai une un peu une
double face un peu sombre un peu obscur
et heureusement les enfants sont là pour
me redonner joie de vivre donc je leur
propose des petits tours de magie de la
jonglerie aussi bien avec des couteaux
qu'avec un diabolo qui s'envole dans les
airs une saison qui s'achève à france
miniature avec la fête d'halloween les
portes du parc se fermeront en novembre
c'est l'heure à présent de tirer le
bilan de l'année avant sa réouverture au
printemps on arrive quasiment à la
fermeture on est très content on a fait
une très belle saison malgré des
épisodes de canicule qui sont toujours
un petit peu compliqué sur les sites de
loisirs
on flirte avec les 200 mille visiteurs
donc cette année c'est une très belle
performance
un bilan en hausse par rapport aux
précédentes années pour france miniature
nous restons dans cette ambiance
d'halloween avec bruno poinsel bonsoir
en soit responsable communication des
fermes de gally basée à saint cyr
l'école qui dispose aussi de sites sur
feugerolles sartrouville ou encore saint
denis
voilà pour les sites et les fermes de
gally déjà en quelques mots c'est un
lieu pour jardiner cuisiner se retrouver
en famille pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas voilà pour partager des bons moments
en famille autour de la nature et des
bonnes choses avec des thématiques à
chaque fois hélas la thématique
forcément cette période automnale c'est
halloween à partir du 26 octobre il y
aura notamment cette fête de la
citrouille
elle permet de creuser les différentes
citrouille et d'avoir des réalisations
comme celles que vous avez ramené
effectivement les citrouilles doigt deux
mois de la fin octobre se la pète des
citrouilles on les a cultivé depuis le
mois de mai dans nos champs on les a
récolté ces dernières semaines et du 26
au 31 on va accueillir les familles et
principalement les enfants pour leur
proposer de participer à des ateliers de
creusement de citrouilles donc les
choses se font très naturellement et
très simplement les enfants viennent
chez nous choisissent la citrouille qui
leur convient il y en a des centaines
ils y font des dessins au feutre pour
donner vie à la citrouille qu'ils ont
choisi les animateurs les découpes pour
des questions de sécurité
et puis après on enlève le chapeau de la
citrouille et les enfants vont avec une
cuillère creuser l'intérieur positionner
la beaujarde et on va toutes ces images
justement qui ont été tournées dans vos
établissements là cette fête de la
citrouille et sur saint cyr l'école
également sartrouville saint denis
exactement sur les trois fermes les
trois fermes ouvertes de la maison alors
ya une particularité à saint cyrille est
un spectacle aussi pour les 5 12 ans
effectivement il y a
des spectacles qui sont données d après
midi notamment autour du thème de la
citrouille d'halloween jeux pan donner
donner trop d'informations pour que le
public est là surprise mais on a voulu
effectivement cette année faire un petit
plus et permettre aux gens qui vont
venir causer leur citrouille de rester
un peu plus longtemps chez nous et de
passer un moment agréable autour d'une
pièce thématiques
c'est toujours un succès ya un
engouement retrouver autour d'halloween
autour de ces différents ateliers ou
est-ce que ça a toujours été plus ou
moins deux cas ces dernières années ça
toujours a toujours bien fonctionné on a
une opération qui est très ludique très
participative et effectivement c'est un
franc succès cette année on a une
nocturne qui se déroule le 30 également
qui s'appelle frisson dans la nuit ou là
le modèle un peu différent c'est entre
19h et 22h où il ya toute une animation
donc dans la nuit dans la ferme ça va
être aussi très sympathique à un moment
original et qui nous permet aussi de
nous renouveler parce qu'il faut
toujours proposer des choses différentes
oui pour les familles qui sont déjà
venus peut-être sur certains ateliers là
ils vont découvrir autre chose et puis
découvrir autrement ce site des fermes
de gally de nuit il ya une ambiance
particulière qui sera mise en place
exactement il ya plein de surprises qui
attendent d'autres acteurs auraient dû
le rassurer les familles avec les
enfants c'est vraiment on vient on vient
en famille c'est un spectacle à
destination des familles
donc il ya eu quelques petites surprises
des rencontres à peu fortuite dans la
pénombre qui vont être très sympathique
c'est encore possible de s'y inscrire
oui c'est malheureusement complexe et
c'est trés il reste plus beaucoup de
place si vous faire très très ville les
à présent voilà il faut il y avait très
rapidement sur notre site internet l'e
shop de grippe ou comme je quittais
lewin 2 secondes pour la fin de cet
entretien ce que vous avez déjà pensé
aux animations qui viendront après pour
noël notamment il y aura des rendez vous
effectivement il y aura plein de plein
de rendez vous aussi bien dans le
magasin autour de l'atelier de
décoration de noël également dans la
ferme ouverte où il ya une crèche
vivante où il rieur plein d'ateliers
pour les enfants
merci beaucoup bruno dans celle
responsable communication des fermes de
gally et d'être venu avec vous avec nous
par bon sur ce plateau et vous restez
avec nous voilà encore quelques instants
mélanie poker va nous rejoindre pour sa
chronique et loisirs du jeudi
[Musique]
halloween ce sera dans une semaine on
vient de le voir il ya beaucoup
d'animations prévues bonsoir mélanie et
y en a quelques-unes qu'on peut encore
mentionner un peu envie de frissonner en
famille halloween vous attend à voisins
le bretonneux la ville vous propose
trois films à regarder en famille ils
sont projetés le samedi 26 octobre à
partir de 16 heures c'est à la salle de
la tour sur images vous aurez sans doute
reconnu la famille adams et souhaite
fantômes ou encore le troisième volet d'
hôtel transylvania l'entrée est gratuite
- l'une des autres ambiances de cinéma
au château de dampierre et oui là c'est
les citrouilles qui sont de sortie alors
c'est pas halloween parce que les
équipes ont surtout souhaité un
réchauffé l'atmosphère parfois brumeuse
de ses vacances en journée on peut se
balader en calèche dans le parc se
déplace bien chaud ou s'amuse à faire
des photos dans un carrosse en
citrouille à la tombée de la nuit
l'édifice se dévoile autrement vous avez
des cerceaux lumineux dans la cour du
château vous avez des bulles lumineuse
sur les temps en temps de 7 hectares
avec six grosses bulles qui viennent
prendre la lumière artificielle certes
mais en tout cas voilà qui met l'accent
sur ce patrimoine et puis tout au fond
sur le pavillon sur l'île eh bien nous
avons créé une ambiance fantastique avec
une lumière orange qui sort de ce
pavillon et qui intrigue tout le monde
voilà une belle citrouille pourra
terminer cette séquence consacrée à
halloween qui nous viennent des fermes
de gally si vous venez nous rejoindre il
n'y a pas qu'à l'oin dans les prochains
jours aussi et non là du côté de château
du château de breteuil on va fêter
plutôt l'histoire de france c'est de
manière un peu original ce qu'il ya des
playmobil alors l'orangerie du château
va abriter plusieurs saynètes de cette
histoire française
l'exposition ceux visés soient les
horaires d'ouverture du château et au
tarif du billet d'entrée habituel
ils sont la collection personnelle d'un
grand collectionneur qui s'appelle
dominique béthune et qui collectionne
tous ces petits personnages depuis plus
de onze ans et il en a un nombre assez
impressionnant et il faut constituer
toute sorte de deux scènes de thèmes
pour parler des grands des grandes
époques de notre histoire je peux vous
y'aura jeanne d'arc et la révolution
française mais y en aura beaucoup
d'autres
et justement toutes ces autres histoires
saynètes à découvrir elles le sont de 26
et le 27 octobre
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants juste après le journal
de la rédaction pour un nouveau 7,8
loisirs et un programme complet sur les
rendez-vous des prochains jours
là sur le secteur dans le département
des yvelines pour terminer ce journal
nous partons non plus à la chasse aux
citrouilles mais à la cueillette des
champignons c'est aussi de saison mais
il faut tout de même prendre quelques
précautions pas moins de 493 cas
d'intoxications liées à la consommation
a de mauvais champignons ont été
recensés ces deux dernières semaines
l'agencé nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation de l'environnement et
du travail appelle à la vigilance
alors pour faire sa cueillette en toute
sécurité l'association des naturalistes
des yvelines propose des balades
encadrées pour apprendre à reconnaître
un cèpe délicieux amy sène pur toxiques
marylène iapichino s'est rendu en forêt
de marie corner du coup l'état comme
soldats
avec son panier ses bottes en caoutchouc
eva est venue accompagnée de sa maman et
ses cousines pour apprendre à
reconnaître les champignons regarde
comme ses fans regardent le pied aussi
aucune méprise possible le groupe d'une
vingtaine de personnes est encadré par
deux experts passionné de mycologie
membres de l'association des
naturalistes des yvelines qui propose
cette sortie avec l'office du tourisme
la première question en général c'est
savoir si c'est bon ou pas bon mais ce
qui est important avant avant cela bien
sûr c'est de reconnaître les champignons
puisque tous les tous ces champignons
aux ondes et sosie la famille va faire
attention car elle est venue avec un
objectif bien précis c'est qu'ils sont
connaissez pas c'est ça on fait une à
mettre avec elle même et ré cinéma -
pour cela car une à son astuce elle
prend en photo les champignons pour
s'assurer de bien les reconnaître
champignons ou laisser sa enroulée on va
demander au monsieur enroulée mortels
mon va m c'est original parce que on a
peu l'occasion de faire ça avec des
experts et généralement on espère
cueillir ce qu'on sait pas trop si c'est
si ces taxis coupaye le met en
champignon va pouvoir se faire eva
trouve le tout 1er septembre dos de la
panade ont défait revient le champignon
bon bien le déterminer par contre là on
peut enlever la terre pour éviter de
mettre de la terre dans le panier donc
enfin un petit couteau et une fois là
bas à condition cependant de ne pas les
confondre
regardez les fip et ben non ça c'était
une feuille je me suis fait typique moi
je me suis fait avoir presque deux
heures de balade en forêt de marly pour
amener des paniers bien remplie dernier
coup d'oeil de l'expert avant de partir
non c'est bien c'est bien vérifier ces
champignons avant de les transformer en
omelette ou en fricassée un réflexe à ne
pas manquer les autorités sanitaires
appellent à la vigilance suite à de
nombreux cas d'intoxication ces
dernières semaines
c'est la fin de cette édition du journal
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité à
locale ce sera vendredi à partir de 18h
pour l'hebdo et puis bien sûr rendez
vous sur notre site internet notre
application mobile et les réseaux
sociaux à 24 heures sur 24
très belle soirée
[Musique]